today X is malaria thankfully that is
the best in the home B of course and I
do excuse the shadows on my face but you
will notice that when I turn my face to
the Sun I'm unable to open my eyes that
is because it is so very bright so let's
not look at me let's look at the dogs
while I tell you that of course we would
love to hear from you throughout the
course of the show as I'm sure Ralph and
Brent have told you already and you can
talk to us using the hashtag Safari live
now for those of you who have not been
with us over the last few days we've
been doing a few experiments with Ronald
the rover to see how animals respond to
him now we've done it with Hasan of the
male leopard we've done with the sticks
pride both of those cats reacted in very
similar ways well the adult Lions
couldn't have been less interested the
Cubs and the young horse owner walked up
to him I'm not sure why they stood up
there it's not because I moved Ronald
and they kind of looked at him smelt him
and then they disappear within a lay
down and relaxed again now the dogs when
we put him down here they did get up
straight away as soon as he moved
towards them and now they've settled
again in the shade so we'll see what
happens I was a little bit surprised by
the slightly startled reaction so I'm
not sure that we're gonna get the same
result that we have with the cats
alrighty that's it down to the other end
of the juma end of this Drive let's go
down to Tristan Dix who's sitting with
to where you are sitting mr. Henry and
so these elephants all around Japan
which is just a little bit south of
where James is as James mentioned my
name is pricilla on camera today I do
have a VM the wildebeest there we go
there's a little thumb from Veeam this
is live it is interactive which of
course means that you can actually ask
questions and get hold of us so hashtags
for life or YouTube chat if you would
like to get hold of us now we have a
beautiful herd of elephants
come down towards Telepan which is in a
way really cool and in another way not
so cool because we were hoping that we'd
find young hasana just sleeping and
resting in this area but he seems to
have moved on although the way these
elephants are all kind of fronting up
I think asana might be lying somewhere
close by kind of looking towards the
[Music]
shady spots just the way that they're
all kind of you see how they all tightly
packed together I thought maybe just
maybe there was a little lipids
injection which could be very possible
we'll have to just look nicely it also
could be because there's a tiny baby in
amongst this so there's a very wobbly
baby maybe a baby that was born at some
stage yesterday it could be or even last
nights because it's really quite wobbly
on its feet the way that it's standing
you can see those little legs are
buckling and moving quite a bit and the
fact that everybody's bunched around it
could potentially mean that it's a
failing newborn the other thing that we
have here is some really big bull
elephants elephants in the background
and so that's causing a bit of a ruckus
in the herd so from Israel you think
that's why they're anxious is that
they're protecting the baby well I think
it's twofold I think not only protecting
the baby maybe they smell a leopard here
and maybe they know that husana was
around in this section but I think more
than anything is that these big bulls
are causing a bit of a ruckus so there
are a number of big boys around here and
they keep chasing some of the females
and you can see look as the male leaves
now look at how this herd has disbanded
arson so the little one is now a lot
more exposed than what it was but
they're all sort of sniffing at it it is
very small that little one so that is a
tiny new baby that is around which is
very cool and so maybe
the female it's in heat and the boys are
causing a bit of panic and that's why
everybody is sort of trying to protect
this little baby in case one of those
big males comes close now you can see
two of the male's just squaring off
there those are the two smaller ones is
the third is a really large male which I
don't quite know the areas he's just on
the right there behind that bush so
maybe he'll come out just now as well
insanity you're wondering if the
matriarch elephant is always the biggest
no not necessarily sometimes you will
find that there will be bigger females
within the herd structure but she might
just be sort of from a different limit
or she might have joined from a
different reason
and so she's maybe not the matriarch of
that particular herd or you will have a
situation where genetically there's a
female that's is the matriarch and
another female that grows up underneath
that female gets slightly larger but yet
she's not as experienced and not as it's
sort of in tune with what's going on
inside they oh no it fell down when did
you just fall I think this one must be
newer than we think maybe a matter of
hours old given that it's look hard
struggling to stand up oh no come on to
your feet
maybe I see mom look look how mom is
picking it up see mom is using its trunk
to try and pick it up look at that isn't
that incredible see all of them so they
wrapped their trunk around its body like
a little harness and they lift it so
that it can get to its feet to get the
strength to be able to stand
I wonder if this baby is not even newer
than we even think maybe during the day
today maybe in the last few hours it's
incredibly hot today so it would dry
very fast if it was born recently I mean
the time for it to dry would be like I
say very quick so maybe it was born late
or this afternoon or around lunchtime
area it's difficult to know but it would
explain why the herd is sticking around
because you would expect like this to
move and not to stand right in the Sun
like they are at the moment but for some
reason they sticking around the baby is
very wobbly so maybe that's the reason
why it's very very cool to see either
way see it's trying to move away I'm
sure this herd is gonna try and find
some semblance of shade it must be
incredibly hot for naught
them but the little baby as well now the
interesting thing about this whole
process is that those females that are
standing there all feel young females
none of those are particularly big you
can see here comes a much larger female
who's actually got much bigger teeth so
mammary glands and so I wonder if she's
not the one that is actually the mother
and she just went for a quick cooling
down in the siblings have just protected
around it I don't see any other females
there that are lactating at the moment
but I could be wrong
now look comes the big male you see how
much bigger he is then the females he's
gonna come towards them and look at how
the females are wrapping around that
little calf isn't this just the most
phenomenal behavior from these elephants
and look at the size difference he
towers way over those females he is
massive in comparison to them in that
little baby is hard to think that it's
going to go from that small if it's a
male all the way to that massive
individual like you see there now we can
definitely confirm that the female that
is in front that's poses to us isn't the
mum so that little one is sucking from
it so amazing to see that the other
members of the herd looked after it
while the female winches to go cool down
she's probably been in the Sun she's
probably had a little exerted a lot of
energy if she's given birth recently and
so while she went to go and cool down
slightly the others looks after and just
wrapped around her and made sure that
they're looking after this little cough
but how cool is that
you've got from absolutely tiny from you
all the way up to you as big as males
can be I mean you can see the height of
his shoulders in comparison to those
females gives you a really good idea is
amazing it just shows you that male
elephants are really not small animals
at all you always see females you think
they've massive and then you see these
males in comparison you can realise just
how big they are at the shoulder in
particular and look at the size of his
head in comparison to those females
heads his head is almost double the size
you can imagine how much strength and
power is inside they're absolutely
incredible how cool is this what a way
to start our safari is it really is the
best way to start is a big herd of
elephants the prospect of a lipid
sitting somewhere here watching all of
this going on it really is a good good
like I say a good omen for a successful
afternoon that we should have
so I believe a lot of you are a bit
concerned worried that this ball will
the cough will elephants are insanely
intelligent animals and while the bull
might be you know close to the coffin
and Mike represents some sort of danger
in terms of he could knock that cough
over you can see what these others are
doing so the adults females and the
sensibly of that little calf have
created a protective barrier so even if
that bull comes they all almost
sacrifice themselves in a way so they'll
get hit by that bull long before that
little car fall and so the Bulls not
going to be interested in hurting its in
any way they are not like lion and
lipids where they'll come around and
they'll try and kill the baby to bring
their female into Easter's male
elephants are not like that at all so
he's just curious
he'll snuff that little elephant and
then now you see he's just walked off
he's no longer even not interested in
what's going on here he knows that
there's no female to mate with your
teens are looking for the female that
isn't Easter say sniffing the ground
sniffing all that done looking around
trying to see which is the female that
they are picking up the scene for that
is an Easter so that little cough
perfectly safe at this stage and then he
needs to worry too much and mom and and
siblings almost there isn't he ticked it
as much as well well keep it as safe as
they can over the next little bit but
this is so cool we're watching an
amazing sort of thing unfold and in
elephants they are such intelligent
animals that to sit and spend time with
them in a situation like this way you've
got the females and the males and these
little tiny calf and see the social
interactions between them is just
absolutely fascinating right well we're
going to stay with our elephant herd
because I don't really want to go
anywhere there's so much that's
potentially could happen here with big
bulls and little babies and like I say
potential of a lipid making appearance
so while we sit yeah I believe James is
out and about with his toys once again
and I think Ronald is now making another
predator acquaintance for the week
he certainly is he's making friends and
he's making friends with that dog that's
fast asleep there look how close he's
got the dogs are completely
disinterested in his presence and I
don't know can we go to his pictures at
possible it's possible to go to his
picture now we have got Ronald's picture
that is the reason or existence the dogs
are not going business ignoring in
tougher packs just kind of water behind
that they none of them have been
flopping down into the getting out of
here's everybody I'm not sure what
happened there but wow we're still
sitting here with the ever-present hyena
and the little Cubs and they've been
getting more and more curious smelling
the air smelling what we're all about
and it's lovely to watch the nature of
wanting to explore the world around them
and as something new comes into their
little world they obviously I really
want to see what it's all about
let the youngsters step those ones
starting to get the little colour of the
adults on the on their faces and look at
that a little bit of sibling love maybe
not often too much love shine between
hyenas probably a little bit of
dominance and it's amazing to see that
we've been watching these youngsters and
even at this young age
they're already marking and putting
little anal pay stings on the grass as
they move around so and that's also for
each other to sniff and smell it's not
for really for other animals they're
already at such a young age establishing
and maintaining their position in the
hierarchy and it's fascinating that one
still got his prize of the warthog tusks
and it looks like he's keeping it and
the others were been trying to get it
away from him but he's quite happy with
it now Aaron you're wondering how you
tell the sexes now that is an extremely
good question because with hyenas in
times gone by people really believed
that they were meredith's meaning that
they are both male and female and now I
don't mean to make anybody uncomfortable
but we want to talk about sixes of
animals and we're talking male or female
and and generally how we tell that is is
whether there is a penis or an OVA or
vagina but with hyenas there is no
external vagina
so they both male and female have
penises with the female it's obviously a
pseudo penis which is any large clitoris
so it's very difficult to tell between
male and female the only thing that you
really need to look at is the size and
so the females are much bigger than the
males but it's rather difficult when
there are little youngsters like this
because both male and female have penis
but it does seem from my observations
and that the females have a larger
pseudo penis than the male's actual
penis so that's that's how I have been
on my deciding between how to decide if
it's a male or female so I know it's a
difficult subject to deal with and not
everybody too comfortable with those
kind of conversations but well it's it's
a reality so that's what makes and sits
hyena part right folks now from one
group of small little babies let's send
you on over to Tristan who's still with
it
lovely little elephant cough
well indeed it's always a toss-up with
which is cuter in terms of the baby
animal world they all I suppose a very
cute it's not very many ugly babies out
there that's for sure but the little one
as you can see is being very well
sheltered not only from the big
rampaging males that are around here but
also from a perspective of this harsh
Sun that we've got this afternoon it is
incredibly warm and so for a little baby
like that it's going to dehydrate and
it's ears are very sensitive still to
the Sun that they could get sunburned
and so it's important that it stays in
the shade of these siblings and adults
and make sure that the Sun doesn't get
on it too much and so you can see it's
perfectly positioned in this little Sun
hitting it every now and then but for
the most part it's nice and shady and
denieth all of those tummies and it can
fit in very well as mom has a little
dust bath and all of the other certain
allow it to regain its strength as it
tries to work out how to use these legs
now the male seems to be coming back
again this looks like the cheeky are one
of the three he's not the biggest but
he's quite cheeky this individual I
think he might gets a rough welcome if
he comes too close look at how these
guys will tighten their ranks and
they'll make sure that they keep that
bull at bay there'll also be a lot of
communication taking place between them
a lot of it we won't be able to hear one
ninth of it we're not going to be able
to hear it's a very low frequency sound
that basically will tell that bull don't
come here there's a little baby you need
to be careful and keep him at bay as
much as possible you can see how you
stop to feed and it's not very perturbed
at all now interestingly enough sorry
now that I look at that big boy elephant
you might notice just above him is
actually a bird that's sitting there and
I didn't notice it very well earlier but
it's sitting and it's just perched and
I'm surprised because this time of the
day in the heat that we've got you would
expect most of the birds of prey to be
riding the thermals and to be arts and
about but this yellow bull kite is just
sitting here and I wonder if it maybe
didn't see an opportunity to feed off
some of the afterbirth of this elephant
because what they will do is even though
yellow-billed kites are able to catch
their own food and they'll hunt termites
and they'll hunt various other small
insects and birds what they are known
for is also coming down onto roadkill
and also any bits of carrion
if behind and so the afterbirth of a
elephant might be the perfect snack for
a yellow bull kite and that's why it
could be sitting here is because of that
reason is the afterbirth might have been
close by and it's now just thrown up
into the tree waiting for the Early's to
move off it can then come down and feed
off it or it's going to feed off the way
the elephants have difficut 'add and
there are a number of insects that might
be around that as well so interesting
though that this bird is in sort of even
though it's not related to the elephants
in any way it's using the elephants for
a food source by the looks of things
that might be wrong but then it might
just be a coincidence but I doubt that
that bird would be sitting for that long
in the bright hot Sun exposed like that
if it wasn't for a reason that it was
waiting for these elephants to move off
or trying to follow them along as they
defecate and in using their dung
basically as a distraction but look at
the power of these and animals it is
absolutely amazing to watch when they
move those trees I hope that you having
a wonderful weekend you want to know do
elephants like to play elephants love to
play Billy they are one of the most
playful animals that we get archer
you'll find if it's a nice cool morning
and it's overcast and there's not too
much wind
then the little baby elephants are a joy
to watch they'll go up and down and
round and round and they will change
treat chase off to birds and warden Zen
parlors and all these other animals
about it's out as they try and work out
how to use the trunk and how to run
nicely and so they're very playful the
adults not so much you don't see big
bull elephants playing too much when
they get really large like the male that
we have here then you're going to see
that they're going to be a little bit
more serious but when they're young bull
elephants and young females then they
play a lot they push each other as well
and they'll try and taste each other's
strengths so lots of playing that goes
on when you're a baby elephant or when
you're an elephant in general actually
and then when they go down to water
Billy they absolutely love water so in a
day like today you'll find that they'll
go into the mud and they'll throw their
mad on all over themselves and they'll
roll around in it and they'll hide
and they'll get up and then they'll live
back down in it and so it becomes a big
game when there's a lot of mud around as
well so they are animals that love to
play a lot you can actually see that a
lot of them are actually covered in mud
at the moment and that's because it's a
warm day beliefs are they even the
adults I think I've gone for a little
mad you wallow to try and keep nice and
cool on a hot day it's like if you are
very hot maybe you go and jump into the
swimming pool and try and cool down I
don't know where you're from Billy but
if you're in the United States I'm sure
that you are not very hot at all at the
moment particularly on the eastern side
of the United States it believe it is
very very cold that side of the world at
the moment but look at that little face
isn't that the sweetest thing is your
tongue hanging out it does look like
it's tongues hanging out doesn't it no
you hot little one alright it will be
okay the fact is is that the adults are
protecting its nicely and making sure
that it is well sheltered and if it
needs water they will guide it through
the to the breast into the mammary gland
to allow it to suckle and to drink
mother elephants are incredibly good
with that so I've seen elephants give
birth before and and watch the whole
process and when they would need that
first bit of milk they'll actually guide
them using the trunk straight towards
their teats and allow them to then
suckle from there so pretty incredible
right well we're not gonna go anywhere
there's no reason to it's amazing to
have the alias back one and two to have
a little baby in amongst him so while we
sit here and enjoy these big pachyderms
let's go across to James and his
beautiful painted dogs the pen dogs have
managed to get up slightly now and
they're having a little bit of a
greeting ceremony because they keep
getting up to golf and have a drink and
then they come back to the shade here
Ronald unfortunately has got no signal
in this area and so he is unfortunately
probably not going to be able to show
you his pictures of the wild dogs
still he got a couple of good ones and
will try and broadcast those at some
time in the meantime I think I'll bring
it to back now I'm Melissa
you've been watching hyenas with Ralph
of course and you say who's got bigger
ears I think that was the question well
the answer is that the wild dogs have
got much bigger ears
let's move slightly so we can get a bit
of view they have got enormous ears wild
dogs and it's because well we think
because their communication during a
hunt is so crucial and what happens when
their hunt is that they can really sort
of bombshell or shotgun if you like out
into the wilderness and they can lose
each other very quickly and then they
need to find each other very quickly so
they have these sort of satellite dish
ears that help them to find each other
they listen to the sounds they can
swivel and pick up probably the smallest
wild dog sound there are and that helps
them to maintain contact during a hunt
for a hyena yes their ears are certainly
far far better than ours but they don't
have the same need to communicate during
a hunt they'll hunt visually with each
other if they hunt together at all I
don't know Ron got a picture at the
moment
I'll just quickly find out from Louise
if we've got a Ronald's picture
but I don't think we do no we don't
anyway
beautiful shots here of them just trying
desperately to stay cool in the Sun like
I say a very very hot day indeed I don't
think these chaps are going to get up
until well at least half past six or so
and that on account of the fact that it
is well it's pretty cold and knots not
pretty cold what did I say
no account the fact that it is so very
hot and I think that ate very well today
earlier on they look pretty full this
morning as blood covering the heads of
them and so I think that although there
may try and kill something this evening
it's unusual it would be unusual all
right we're gonna go and have a quick
look at Ronald's picture now he's got to
got a picture of one dog who's got his
back to him it's not the best picture
Ronald's managed to get to it but I'm
not going to move in for him
he bird you asked a very good question
you asking to wild dogs live now I've
taken the last time I check something do
you like $0.18 of dogs in the kruger
national or less
yes well everybody it seems like when
there's problems elsewhere what do we do
we come back to the hyena den and it is
still buzzing with the youngsters so
that's not such a problem is it I
wouldn't say so because I'm really
enjoying sitting here these youngsters
are up to all sorts and they've been
greeting each other and mocking and
trying to get the adults to play with
him and then getting in trouble and then
going back to lying down but this never
stops that one stole with his little
warthog tusks he's got his little trophy
and he's working it nicely and working
it on his teeth it's probably quite good
for him as little Cubs and puppies do
they need to chew on lots of things to
help strict strengthen their teeth and
and also sometimes they do teeth so they
drop the name oak teeth and then they
get their adult teeth that's quite
interesting and that one's slightly
older one - it's got its permanent teeth
comes through already the teeth did look
quite sturdy so I think so couple of the
other really black Cubs look they've got
those really fine sharp teeth and when
we do get to see them the ones that are
becoming a little bit lighter a little
bit older but it doesn't matter it
doesn't put you in a different position
in the hierarchy depending on your age
it it all depends on the position of
your mother and very difficult to go up
in the pecking order with with hyenas
they can be very slight changes within
the within the matriarchy and in the
pyramid and look at that that's a lovely
view of these little track and there if
you had to see baby hyena tracks in the
bush he would be very confused because
you don't often see that
and we always see adults moving around
but if we had to see a little one like
that I'm sure there would be lots of
trackers and that would be confused
having seen only one little baby hyena
trek right folks we are going to keep on
sitting ere it is so exciting and I'm
sure the later it gets the more that
might happen but in the meantime we're
gonna send you on back to James with
those painted dogs we're still here with
the wild dogs we think we figured out
why you keep having to crash cut away
from us
it's Ronald's fault - apparently so
we'll avoid using him for a little while
and try and sort that out now Lady Bird
we were talking about the ages of wild
dogs and how long they live I don't know
how far into my answer I got or you got
but basically something I like 80% of
the dogs in the Kruger or less than 80
no less than five years old they have
potential lifespan probably around ten
and unfortunately out here of course
there are lions and hyenas and there are
all sorts of other predators that will
try and kill them from time to time and
there are also difficulties with coming
into contact with domestic dog diseases
like canine distemper and rabies and the
absence of all of that yes they probably
do live for about ten years but in these
very difficult conditions despite their
very high breathing rate really they
will probably find that they are seldom
live beyond five years out here
I'm just trying to find the exact
reference for that
I can't at the moment anyway we will try
and find it to some stage it is quite
interesting though that they should live
such short lives despite the fact that
there are such successful hunters
hello amazed man you are a new viewer
today and I hope you remain as amazed as
your name suggests you should is
wonderful to have you with us and thank
you for giving us of your time and of
your intellect of course you've asked
how fast they can run well it's
difficult to record her arse runs the
figure I've just these six kilometers an
hour
which is about calling 45 miles per hour
they can sustain a speed like that for
some time the big thing that wild dogs
is their ability to maintain that's for
a long period I don't think like a
cheetah for example which must catch
within the first sort of quarter mile or
so will they run out of steam they run
much faster of course so those are the
two coursing predators of Africa the
wild dogs and cheetah and these chaps
have a very different sort of burn
strategy for catching and it's relies a
lot on their stamina
all righty I think we're going to just
move around a bit here see if we can
retrieve Ronald while we do that we're
gonna go back to Tristan and his rather
fascinating a small elephant sighting
well it is fascinating James it is
really interesting to watch I think that
this elephant was born during the day
today so we know that Steve was here
this morning there were no elephants
here and I have a funny feeling that it
was born right here and that's why it's
still learning how to move around I can
just see it coming out of this wall of
sort of elephants that are around us
these some big bulls are really large
male has just arrived now as well a
massive individual that is slowly
starting to come this way and they all
sniffing around that area so I want to
go and have a little look there just now
I went waits until that massive male
varies you see look at the size of him
he's got big tusks he's bigger than the
other bull that we had just now so he's
old and wrinkly and massive Tassimo Chi
sniffing in the air he's got his trunk
up just smelling around and he's set for
a very long time very close to where
those other elephants are and he was
sniffing the ground and I wonder if that
wasn't where it gave birth that maybe
just could be that situation Julie I
think I'm getting this right is Megan
correct me if I'm wrong but you are
asking if lots of elephants would be
more protective of a young one than a
few elephants is that the correct way I
think so I'm not represent you I'd broke
up a little bit as you were coming
through but if that is the case then the
more elephants you know at the end of
the day the better is going to be that
altogether but you are seeing if a young
male elephant would be as protective
there's something wrong with that little
calf did you see that sorry Judy I'll
get into your question now but it looks
like it's mass there's a split you see
that between its trunk and its mouth
almost like it's got a cleft palate
that's really interesting I've never
seen that in my life before it's not its
mouth its mouth is lowered down by the
looks of things and just now there was a
funny sound coming from in amongst him
and I thought maybe its trunk sounded
like it was blocks and it seems as
though there might be a little issue
there you see that that's doesn't look
like its mouth its mouth looks like it's
lower than that always it's its mouth
just could be a funny angle no it is its
mouth sorry it's just the folds of skin
it looks okay at this stage now back to
what you are asking Gina you're asking a
young infant would he be as protective
yes a young elephant if he's part of
that family and he's part of if he was
born to the same mother he's going to be
very very protective of that little one
he's going to come to its defense and
some of these elephants that are around
that little baby as well look how fluffy
its tummy is super fluffy protect it and
try and make sure that it is looked
after and it is made to you kind of feel
safe and that there is a boundary
between it and everybody else you'll
find the situation that no matter if
it's a young male or a female if they
are part of that family unit and it's
the same mother they will be highly
protective of this sibling and make sure
that the little one is safe and you can
see look as the little one takes a step
so the rest of them take a step as the
no one takes and in the wrist goes so
they all trying to kind of keep it as
safe as possible the whole grouping of
them and so even though some of those
will probably not be this females
offspring they are trying to kind of
make sure that they protect it as much
as possible but there you go see it's
trying to suckle every now and then
shame nipple when you are brand new I
think you are in you a few hours old if
that maybe even an hour or two this is
so cool to see we have been so so spoilt
and humor the last few months we've had
so many amazing baby animal sightings
we've had Tandy's Footloose the ville de
bees Scott's a little baby wildebeest
that was born we've got this one we've
got all kind of the little Lapwing
chicks
I mean clever chicks that we had we've
had a lot of baby animals that we've
been able to see take their first few
steps in life and so amazing to be a
part of this and I'm 99.9% sure now bat
that kite
he's here for the afterbirth and that
they gave birth right here the fact that
this herd is also sitting for as long as
it is in this area would definitely mean
that they are probably just waiting for
this little one to start kind of being
able to move and start trying to
actually kind of be able to be on its
feet and solid enough to that they can
go and get out of the hot Sun but until
then yes everybody's in going to be
strata stay stationary as possible you
can see this a bit of aging RG bhaji
that's going on you see and look at how
the female reaction you get to involve
very quickly she says they're coming to
investigate what's going on who needs
protection they all gonna come in and
try and just huddle around make sure
that everything's okay little ones
squashed into the middle now hopefully
they don't think that I'm the cause of
all of this because I have we've done
nothing wrong we've just been sitting
here there was just one cheeky little
male that tried to go and investigate in
look aisle that an adult female that
just came in she's coming to investigate
as well so she's one of the older
females within the herd and she's just
coming sniffing this new little calf
making sure everything's okay working
out who this new member is and it's
amazing to me that vocalizing you can
see even though their female is not
related to that tiny look off they've
all come running in to try and protect
it not just the most amazing you can see
this all along that big bull elephant I
would say the trunk height where it's
kind of touching up towards the tusks is
probably maybe close to about six foot
just under six foot and that's
completely sort of from ground to the
tusks and that's not actually stretched
out you can see the rest of the trunk is
coiled at the bottom is his trunk will
probably easily be about eight feet if
it was really stretched which is really
long if you think about it it is
absolutely fascinating to see how
they're able to manipulate that trunk
but big bull elephant like at between
750 about seven and a half feet probably
maximum on a trunk like that absolutely
incredible now just the size difference
of these animals is phenomenal there's a
massive female the one behind him so it
looks like a young animal that's coming
up behind that big bull see if you saw
her by herself you would think that that
is a really large female a big massive
matriarchal female but she is dwarfed by
the massive males she looks just like in
the poor one in comparison in fact both
these males that we've got yeah while
huge they almost look like pillars on
either side of her protecting her at the
moment
look at that you've seen these two tall
kind of animals they're facing in the
same way and almost looks as though they
are theirs in keeping everybody safe and
useful issues
how amazing is this and also just to see
the dynamics of having the big bulls you
know I'm sure the Bulls have been
attracted because of the birth so they
would have heard vocalizing they would
have heard a commotion and they
interested they know that there's
something going on and so they come in
to check there might also be a female in
heat but I mean it's my case of that
these earrings were giving and so these
big males have come and they've smelled
hormones and they've smelt that there's
a female that's discharging and so
they're coming to try and investigate
what's going on incredible to witness
though and amazing how these aliases
form this barrier between them is he's
gonna lie down he looks like you might
be lying down he's stretching his legs
up are you going to sit down bueno
anything he's just giving his back legs
a nice big stretch he's an old boy you
can see on his hips they sinking in a
little bit there so that's a sign of age
I would say he's probably easily in his
late 40s maybe even starting to approach
50 and remember that the elephants in
this area most of them went to live
farce 55 because of the type of terrain
we're in and the diet that they have
very abrasive towards their teeth and so
their lifespan is slightly shorter than
those elephants that you'll find in the
Masai Mara and even in other parts of
Africa so I would say he's a very old
boy that and still masters though he's
intimidating I can tell you that when he
comes towards you he's very intimidating
right now we're going to like I say just
carry on sitting here and why not is so
much happening there's so much amazing
interaction to watch and so while we
enjoy these in ease let's go across to
my friend Brent who for the first time
ever sounds like he is struggling to
find these 20 colored cat in the Mara
yes yes Tristan I think you're more
intimidating than that big elephant bull
however we've actually covered quite a
lot of ground since you last saw us
we're now on the edge of the Mara if I'm
hoping for a bit of luck with a paradise
pride all them all musketeer male lion
coalition however none are being kind at
the moment so we're not seeing anything
not much to eat around here as well are
they gonna land hopefully even catch up
with them so it's quite a lot of nice
bird life though even in this really
windy woodenly conditions so Adrienne if
you have a look next to us is it hard no
they throw away darkness it's Little Red
Birds okay they've all landed in that
tree and the same tree as the black bird
there that one there before my finger
oh no the black birds gone but the
little red ones are still there oh
Guinea files on the other side so zoom
in right on my finger there we go
isn't that really Ono if they go down
the wind is not good for birding there
are African fly finches and it was a
yellow mantled Widow as well we tried we
tried let's go try find something that
doesn't move around so much in the wind
I have seen two very good birds in our
wonderings today Eurasian Marsh Harrier
and and a corncrake now you might want
to remember how excited I got about a
corncrake at cheetah Plains but in the
Mara corn cakes are not nearly as as
rare and actually you do flash them
reasonably often when you're driving
through wet grassy areas oh we do have
one of my favorites though again
disappearing in the wind quite low at
the moment some of the sound banks
coming out lots of hippos I think
there's gonna be quite a bit of
competition between the different hippos
as we head into this dry spell so we
could be seeing quite a few more hippo
fights and the like oh you looks like a
grumpy grumpy sod that I does now I
asked you a little bit earlier about if
we deemed survival as success what was
the most successful species in the
history of the earth we've got some
really good guesses in cockroaches sea
sponges bacteria all sorts of
sorts of guesses tortoises mosquitoes
frogs sharks but it looks like for the
first time in a very long time I gotcha
I gotcha all it is a bit of a trick
question so if we actually have to think
about it in terms of survival and the
living organism that has been exactly
the same for the longest period of time
and is survived through the age of the
dinosaurs the dawn of the mammals the
Great Sea Age the volcanic age is
blue-green algae
spirogyra pond scum
we have 4.2 billion years and change
that's the oldest fossil that has been
found of spirogyra is 4.2 billion years
old isn't that incredible absolutely
fascinating well I think it's
fascinating hippos they don't seem too
impressed with spirogyra hey they're
starting to get ready to head out and in
see they're getting a bit more mobile
and heading out to go graze on the green
grass there however even though they
share their kwatak habitat with
spirogyra don't eat it any strange thing
that eats seaweed is I mean while
spirogyra is people LG tablets how Val I
think it's got some form of vitamin and
whatnot that's at yes the end let's not
to talk about spirogyra any longer let's
go across to ralph with some very very
cute hyena Cubs yes indeed thanks Brent
well folks I still haven't been able to
drag myself away from this hi Nadine
because there's been all sorts going on
once more there was some kind of smell
that just came through to the sign again
because we didn't hear anything it must
have been something in the breeze that
really made them all jump up and take
notice
and all the youngsters disappeared down
the hole and the adults were looking
very concerned now it seems to have
settled a little bit but there is still
a little bit of an edginess to them and
they do seem to be a little bit worried
about something I wonder what it could
have been whether it was the smell of a
of an a lion what I don't know but there
was something that really worried them a
minute ago and I can promise you it
wasn't us because we didn't do anything
different to what we've been doing all
the time
it was really strange but they seem to
have settled now
and the ones walking off with his trophy
they still the same one with it
he is not relinquish in that getting a
lovely chew on it it's absolutely
wonderful so folks I think we are going
to leave shortly however and because I
do want just pop it in at the river and
see what's happening down there so let's
say goodbye to these hyena for now but
we will be back with them in the next
few days tomorrow we're going to be
popping across the river so we're gonna
give these hyena a bit of space but in
the meantime let's head on over to
Tristan all the way back in South Africa
being with all the little car with a
little cough in it and so there's a bit
of chaos that is now starting to happen
in a bit of pushing and shoving and
everybody's getting a little upset with
each other at the moment I think it's
such close proximity that when the Bulls
arrived then the females get a little
bit antsy and they try and kind of push
them away it's really interesting if you
watch this bull on the right hand side
he's starting to come in now and we just
know as he was coming in that's when the
female started to push him and try and
get rid of him now the little one he's
actually quite far from that male so
he's probably gonna be alright at the
moment he's not gonna have a situation
where the female will push him just yet
but if he starts coming from behind
where that female is she certainly will
turn around and try and push him away
but it's amazing just to watch the
actions that are taking place in the way
that these males kind of engage with the
females and how it all kind of works
together and these females are highly
tolerant of each other but as soon as a
male comes in yet even the sub adult
males they're getting a rough welcome
and he's not a very warm reception at
all he's do you look at a female she can
just come straight in no worries no
issues but the boys when they start
coming now look what this female is she
might start turning because the other
male is coming from the back now so he's
coming towards now let's see what
happens you see he's just coming to you
I think he just wants to investigate
more than anything but the adult female
if she feels like he's too close might
turn around and start to push him but
you see how they all sniffing each other
you see sniffing at the genitals of the
female and just trying to work out
what's going on why is everybody so kind
of interested in this tiny little being
and just trying to work out the exact
sort of reasoning for what's happening
now here comes the big matriarch as well
she's what I think is the matrix it me
the largest and the oldest of the
elephants that we have here and look at
how that male backs away immediately as
that big female comes in now we've got a
standoff between the two of them you see
this
and in back he goes now the big bull is
coming now stall dribbling
he's an absolute monster now this will
give you a really good idea of just how
large this male is in comparison to
everybody else and if you see him kind
of walking towards those females
older females chase that male aways and
not for you to close and I wonder what
this big males going to get a reception
from this older female as well you see
the hood is trying to just kind of push
the little calf away take it away from
these big boys the end of the day they
don't want to really be too close
because if one of those big boys pushes
too hard you can obviously hurt a number
of them so everybody's just being a bit
weary fascinating to watch though
unbelievable I would love to see that
tiny baby with that male just to see how
much bigger he it's actually quite scary
how he's dwarfing the rest of them
he is monstrous that little baby's the
size of his front foot just the round
part of his front foot you can see the
little baby hidden riding and underneath
his legs there so there it is then so
baby mother and then that could be the
dad in terms of the baby height so you
can see how the very height is different
because you could possibly ask for and
he's such a gentleman from considering
he's in must and there's a lot of
commotion you can actually see his
almost looks like he's sleeping you see
his eyes are closing
are you tired and hot and wondering why
everybody's not paying attention to you
and it's probably seamless or before
many times a male of the size would
certainly have been through these kind
of things before and has probably seen
it all that's why it's not really that
interested compared to the younger males
that maybe this day really witnessing at
different it's not with a young calf in
it see his trunk up sniffing now that's
the direction that we think husana was
left in so somewhere there so he's just
nothing the breeze from where husana was
lying earlier
lemon you wondering if a nursing mothers
fee met what a nursing mother dies would
another member of the hood come in and
suck all that baby and take over
so no unfortunately not elephants are
very particular but they're baby
suckling from them they try and make
sure that the nutrients that they're
getting or giving is to their baby and
to give their baby the right sort of up
started and to get them the right
nutrients that they need remember that
that female even though she's now well
there's this youngster that is around
that female needs to breed to be
lactating and if she's lactating she
needs to make sure that her calf is
surviving before she tries to look after
yeah this you might be able to possibly
produce enough milk for two but it would
be a very big risk that she would take
and she could theoretically you know
endanger her own offspring and so she'd
rather look after her own offspring
first and foremost before she does
anything else and so no they don't adopt
others it's never been recorded as far
as I know and so unfortunately if the
mother were to die then normally the
calf also dies as well gets left behind
and unfortunately gets then Ponder's or
various other now these have moved off a
little bit I want to go and check where
that kite is sitting because the kites
are still patients I just wanna go back
and have a look see if we can find some
semblance of this afterbirth it might be
really cool to go and have a look we're
right at the back we've been sitting in
the shade ever so nicely VM and I and
kind of forgot that there is this
blazing sunshine that's after birth
right
there's something that resembles after
this let's go over there quickly and
we'll come back to that just now because
they were all sniffing here as kites
you're still sitting right there so I
think maybe this little calf was born
somewhere in this general little section
let's have a look maybe even they've all
he writes it looks very dark from
already from here
I just want to see this elephant dung
well this is definitely she gave birth
right there so you can see there's after
birth right in the Sun it's still fairly
wet so we must have missed this birth by
I don't even know maybe an hour or two
if that I think that's about as close as
where you must have been to be seeing an
elephant give birth and that's why the
kite is here so that's why the class has
being patient it's waiting for the
aliens to go and this is the best view
we'll ever get our yellow bull kite look
how post that is isn't that cool so for
those of you that some of you may have
never seen a yellow billed kite but it
is really cool to see and you can
actually see on the beak it looks as
though there's some stuff on it so maybe
it's already been feeding in the areas
of chase a little bit but definitely
this is where it gave birth and it must
have been like I say at some point early
this afternoon or maybe even around
lunchtime because it's still very red
and still quite moist and in this heat
that would dry out incredibly quick
periods that's after birth and you'd
have a situation where it would be a
little bit more kind of brown and drier
than what you see there obviously gave
birth right here in the section which is
absolutely phenomenal it's why that
little one is as wobbly as it is how
cool is this
so we minutes away from would have
enjoyed documenting that that's for sure
because the elephant breath I've seen
[Music]
because that's weird as a mission II
kind of happened and then maybe some
more over here maybe this is where it
started and she eventually went in there
where it was a bit Shadia but you can
see what VM was talking about here in
front there's a big dark patch on the
soil and you can see actually where this
sand has been kicked and moved so maybe
that's where it started and then she
moved it along and it's ended up over
there but that is so cool to see very
very cool
monkey wondering where's the cleanup
crew and who is the cleanup crew so
guide monkey the cleanup crew would
probably be the form of this yellow bull
kite
Tony Eagles Bettany Eagles vultures
hyenas even those wild dogs at James
Smith we're not far from there maybe the
dogs come around the side and come and
have a look Kasana
if he's around and they move off he
might come and have a little look at it
at the end of the day a free meal that
he might be able to clean up not sure if
you'd eat it but you never know in
lipids sometimes I'm alive most
certainly would eat that if he came
across that given the state he's in so
number of different things would clean
up and a number of different things will
be here but that kite is gonna give
first sort of go at it for now
as soon as other birds spot that kite
they like bats and ears they're gonna
come in and they're gonna try and keep
you know that kite away than the bigger
then the bigger the animal that is
around will just dominate what's going
on and if I mean it comes that will be
gone in all of about one's thinking that
will just sort of gulp most of that down
very very quickly right just to see if
wasana is here those innings are
starting to move off a little bit into
the bush they're going into quite a
thicket at the moment and so the little
calf is kind of with them we can still
see them very nicely but they starting
to move into thickets a little bit and I
really don't want to follow them through
thickets just do a little loop for for a
sauna see if we can find him if we can't
find him maybe the aliens are out when
we get back and we'll be able to the
native another amazing visual of that
little cough but what a special sighting
now well we kind of look the person I
think that's go back across to brint
near Smith hopefully he's going to have
some luck at some point this afternoon
otherwise he's going to be a very grumpy
fella
here we go I'm always happy I've seen
birds yeah a black-headed heron stalking
through the grassland after manner of
insects grasshoppers mostly there are
such elegant birds now we've been
driving through the long grasses and
we've done it a loop around the river
with no luck
but fortunately here on the topi plains
we have some shorter grass and with the
shorter grass means less animals maybe
topi living on the topi blends strangely
enough we got a nice big herd of Impala
me odd little Tommy are armed there's a
topi funny-looking beasties aren't there
and we are hoping we get a bit of
lacquer and yeah so there's food for
predators here so we can only hope that
there are some predators about if you
listen very carefully I'm going to keep
quiet just go to the left a little bit
there Edwin you see there's that topi
lifting his nose to the left from the
Impala keep coming keep coming keep
coming
past the Impala mmm bit more and here we
go now that's a nice big male topi in
there there are gonna be coming into the
rut quite soon and if you listen
carefully you'll hear these funny little
grunts every now and then there's a
little Tommy sleeping behind him so
interruption geese in the foreground
very funny little bit bit
so it's not quite taupey right yet but
it will be coming and then there can be
some particularly fierce battles between
the topi
you can hear some scaly spur files in
the distance as well sound like people
chatting away to me
I'm for sure having the wind that might
be affecting what you can hear now we
had a question from oh no I've gone
black no maids can you help me out
quickly I had a question from handicap
which I can't remember the question
either mix I'm so sorry got distracted
well the animals around me
ah yes how far away is the closest city
to the Messiah Maya well um we've got
lots of villages close by but the the
cursus city or is no rock and on
European and American standards it's not
a city adored via a small town but in
Kenyan standard is the city it is also
the seat of the county government we are
in the Rock County the Masai Mara is
within the rock country and it is as the
crow flies if you can go straight in an
airplane over the mountains probably
only about 60 or 70 kilometers away to
drive probably around 150 however if I
say 150 kilometres did it go it's just
down the road you know there's a little
a little toddle down the road in the car
however that will can take you that
portion can take you four hours five
hours due to the nature of the roads the
roads down to the Mara leave quite a lot
to be desired especially after its
rained a lot which it had just before we
came down and so yes it can be very very
a very sticky that red as some of you
know not this leave the leave before
when we're coming back from Uganda
Batman Rebeca myself faith and Jamie
got stack our in our car slid off the
road
we were not driving so there's no
marshmallows for me I was not the driver
I was a passenger I had no control and
we we left Nairobi at about 12:00 and we
only got into camp at 1:00 a.m. and we
were stuck for about five and a half
hours in the mag we had to find every
little motorbike Ken passed and he had a
friend who knew a friend who had a
friend who had a tractor so it's a quite
part of organizing but eventually a
tractor pull this all out add a body
lever nish and then we and then we had a
flat tire so we only gotten to camp at
about 1:20 in the morning so it was
quite quite an adventure a long a long a
long drive getting stacks friend every
now and then and but it's fun to get
stuck every now and then but not too
often I prefer to just not get stuck I
leave the getting stuck to Ralph
who's just to that west of me thanks
Brent yeah now I'm not I'm not that good
at getting stuck but I am good at trying
it's just fun to just pull off the road
here because we want to just have a look
at this
group of birds that you do have building
the nests we have stopped job before but
it's always lovely to see a lot of
masked Weaver's and in the morning
they've been very busy at working on
those nests and they've chosen an
excellent site in this acacia or now as
they call it the chillier and it looks
like a sweet thorn the chillier or Casey
as we used to call it but a very good
site and now Haven here you've asked the
question is it easy for for humans or
people to contract sleeping sickness
from the city flies and while Haven it
is now quite known and I know the
figures in in the southern African
region I need to find out a little bit
up here in Kenya but in the southern
African region they used to have it very
prevalent but they got it under control
with a lot of the dips and spraying that
they did and so the city flies have been
really reduced to very much no problem
at all
but up high in Kenya I have heard people
saying that they've been bitten by a
tsetse flies I haven't heard of anybody
getting sleeping sickness but I do need
to find out if there is any prevalence
of a tear in Kenya now I don't know if
you can hear these birds calling but for
me that is very much the sound of summer
let's just listen a little bit
when I was growing up as a little
youngster we used to spend a lot of time
fishing on the river and we used to
really welcome the sound of weavers
because that meant that the fish were
going to start coming on the bite really
brings joy to my heart always wonderful
how they do that dance at the bottom of
it hang upside down that's a little bit
of look at me look how pretty I am and
yellow and bright and look at how well I
spoke to my little home trying to
attract the female and if that's the
message he's portraying prey on top so
he exposes all these colors from
underneath when he hangs upside down and
that's mostly what the colors are for
with birds they can very often lose all
the colors in the non breeding months
down to the malt and females animate to
show that he's the strongest the wisest
and the best house Boulder off the lot
and you can also do his dance the best
there's a whole intricacy going on here
natural selection and it's obviously
hard at work on the inside too
sure know are we getting it right now
black cat you're saying that they sound
like tickety's I think it was I'm not
just quite sure what that is but I'm
assuming it's a bird chickadees no
chickadees I wonder is that small little
is that small little chickens or
chickadees I'm not quite sure what
chickadees are that is that a French
word so your phone say oui
OPA no put it on a real show
okay so FC has just informed me that
it's a little bird that they find in
North America part of the tit family
well that's news to me it seems as soon
as one starts calling then they all try
to compete now Linda you're saying that
the noise is putting you to sleep
well I'm glad that it is Linda well not
that we want you to fall asleep while
you're watching our show but if it's
soothing well then that's great but as I
say it can bring out emotions in all
sorts of different people and different
emotions at that and like I said so for
you it's making you feel sleepy for me
it makes me feel excited for summer and
wanting to go down the river and catch
some fish
now you're wondering if both male and
female roost in the nest at night they
can do but generally the males they can
stay you see that's why this is a lovely
tree for them because they can stay
outside it depends on the weather really
if it's very cold
they will huddle up on the inside in
their little ball inside that nest and
so when they huddle together they then
save energy and weavers do this quite
regularly because when you shiver to
stay warm this is obviously a response
and it does assist the body in warm and
mammals will then shiver when it's very
cold and that assists in in survival but
what the weavers do they huddled
together and in so doing keep their
warmth together and then they don't need
to shiver to stay warm because they need
to save their energy for the work that
that one is doing right there and so if
they spent the night shivering they
wouldn't have any energy in the morning
to constantly work on their house and do
the little dances that they're doing and
the ones that do this the best are the
sociable weavers in Namibia which are
the largest nest builders in the world
but they build a massive communal nest
with all different entrances at the
bottom so all the all the different
couples will still have their little
nests but as as part of the greater nest
and so when it's very cold they're all
huddled together and they don't need to
shiver to stay warm and when it's very
hot it's very cool inside so it all does
interlink with thermoregulation as well
and you really don't want to waste your
energy shivering to keep warm all night
especially when you've got hard work to
do the next day such as building these
very elaborate nests and a tree Weaver
is defined by a bird that can tie a knot
and so not all Weaver's or true Weaver's
like the Red Bull Buffalo Weaver
is not a true either his nest is just an
array of sticks all over the place and
the white broad Sparrow Weaver similar
thing is just an array of grass pieces
all over the place but the true weavers
are the ones that can tie a knot and
they normally make a ball nest with some
kind of little tunnel coming into it and
that's how you also tell from looking
just at the nest which kind of weave it
is these mosque weavers they don't have
a real entrance or a tunnel into the
nest they've just got a very elaborate
hole but the other weavers
they make a very long tube which is all
down to assisting in stopping predators
and getting inside and eating their
chicks or they or their eggs and so it
does help to protect them and even when
the wind really blows hard they still
find inside that nest so it's all
protected and it's very very intricate
from the weavers SC in New York you're
wondering how many chicks they can have
in the nest at one time it's generally
up to about four but what I've seen the
most it's normally between two and three
so the average I would say two or three
and they don't always all survive
sometimes the wind can throw that little
nest all over the place and they can
fall out and they very often make the
nests over water which does also assist
in protecting against predators but when
their wind really blows and one of them
falls out they got a plop into the water
and so we knew this as little kids and
we knew that they would be fish waiting
underneath them ready to catch these
little chicks and so we used to go
fishing underneath these nests and we
used to catch massive catfish
immediately below there because those
fish were waiting just for the little
chicks to plop into the water and we
only fish for sport so even though we
caught those big catfish that were
waiting for the
Weaver's to fall out the nest we had our
fun with the fish and then we let him go
to go and eat little chicks falling out
the nest and return them to the
murderous rolls calling once again
fabulous look at the little dance once
more really makes you feel part of their
little gang and this mentally call have
you had the dance goes with the cool as
well alrighty folks I think we've set
here with these wheelers for long enough
it was a lovely little encounter that
and you never pass up even just the
small little things that we can see it
just makes for a more complete bush
experience doesn't it but we've got
other things to find and see so let's
start up and it's hit on out
see what else we can find by Weaver's
good luck in attracting the females so
they're all sitting in the background
mining about your building good luck
[Applause]
[ __ ] so we're gonna go along this road
here the hitting sort of towards the
river a little bit and then along the
River Road and then from there we'll
stop with whatever nice walls and all
organism or whatever else we can find
but what if while we're doing that let's
send you on back to South Africa with
James who I believe is driving around
one of my favorite here is in chat with
there
I'd suggest what he does of course is go
home because of these quarter after
hospice fix he may be arrested and found
in jail tomorrow
now we have a hippopotamus over there
just exciting Ralph has muscari
and is going to be out for a while this
evening it's quite exciting okay good we
have a very peaceful scene now I was
actually quite jealous as I was sitting
there listening to Ralph's society more
bits and pieces of it I love weavers as
well and they make me feel like summer
also so I got an exact feeling from the
sighting you had there of those weavers
we've left the wild dogs we're going to
go back to them as it cools down a bit
but for now well again to enjoy the
hippopotamus and some Egyptian gooses
they are swimming gently towards him a
Sunday afternoon swim they are having
looks like a very leisurely stately swim
across the water and despite what you
might think they are not looking for
fish they're looking for algae and
greenery but I will tell you that they
do eat fish I've seen them eating fish
in this very water hole
very peaceful nice little breeze coming
up giving us a bit of pouf and I will
tell you unfortunately that Ronald is
out of action for the rest of the day he
is apparently the reason you kept having
to leave us and the wild dogs he created
a bit of a blockage with the signal oh
and a lovely woodland Kingfisher coming
down to have a drink it's disappeared
now don't worry about it Sebastian I'm
sorry I threw yukine under the bus there
he did he did sort of go across over
there can you see him there
anyway let's go back to the hippo now SC
from New York you're wondering about
hippopotami and their primary diet well
you see they are largely eaters of grass
they will eat aquatic vegetation from
time to time but they mostly feed on
grass at night so they spend their days
in the water doing not very much at all
except sort of fouling the water with
their dung which this fellow did as we
arrived and then they move out as the
Sun Goes Down and there graze which is
why around water holes especially in
sort of grassland rather than woodland
areas you will find lawns all around
water holes and John riverbanks and
that's from the hippos that graze them
into these wonderful sort of golf course
like lawns and you'll find patches of
that here you find it mostly on the
banks of the Mara River of course lots
and lots of hippos there in fact a hippo
is not even an anomaly it's always nice
to have one because they occur singly
quite often than this we are near a
river and we don't really have a river
like that yeah as of Jummah we have
these water holes where young bulls like
this fellow come to eke out their days
until they are big and strong enough to
take a pod or get into a pod all where
old fellows come to retire and spend
their dotage in peace in amongst the
egyptian geese
blacksmith lapwings three-banded
clubbers sip can you see in that Bank
there there's a white thing shining can
you see this any idea what do you think
that is it looks like an eggy but I put
an egg in there very strange I might
have to go investigate that find out
what it is anyway that's what's going on
here now I have prevailed upon the
greatest French Japanese air force pilot
to put his drone in the air and so that
is what we are going to do while we
investigate that eggy while we do that I
think we'll hand you over to Brent Leo
Smith who I believe is an and I quote
bundling about the plains of the Mara
hello welcome back well it seems like
the big cats are avoiding us I think AJ
and I tomorrow are gonna have to head
deep south towards Tanzania I see if we
any luck with some cheetah down there
now I've got a question from handicap is
that has climate change affected the
Mara now our climate change is always a
bit of a controversial topic I like a
good controversial topic as much the
next one so the earth has had climate
changes far more drastic over its old
history there is no doubt that human
beings are having effect on the climate
and and and on on the earth itself as an
immediate effect but in terms of
actually seeing climate change effects
50 or 60 years even a hundred years it
was in an area like this that those
changes are not going to be as apparent
as they would be somewhere as stark as
the polar icecaps for example way it's
very easy to see I'll notice a change
where here you might have a graduate
gradual drying out or gradual whittling
but you would need to take a lot longer
time to really see and look at some very
nitty-gritty data and go and mean
averages of moles per year so it's very
difficult to say that or see that there
has been in any at all change in the
Mara some people are saying it's a bit
drier than it used to be but I've learnt
after being the bush for a long time it
was it was always hotter last year or
it's always the hottest year this year
the driest year this year and there's a
lot of pub talk so to speak and until
you can actually get a hold of some
proper data and facts it's it's very
impossible it is impossible to tell and
I don't like guessing so I would say
there's been a very minimal effect but
as I say until you can actually rather
than listening to to pub talk and you
must remember a lot of stuff posted on
social media is an absolute load of
nonsense there's very good things about
that how connective the world is at the
moment there's also very bad things and
there's a lot of very bad articles that
haven't been researched very well that I
just popped out there now taken as
gospel traffic jam so you've got to be
very careful when you broach subjects
and stuff like that I so it is and
there's a very controversial and there
is no doubt that human beings are having
an effect yeah whether the earth is
warming in a natural cycle or or not
that that
we'll take a lot more sort of they're
very in-depth research had to find out I
mean if you think about it the earth was
so much warmer a couple of hundred
thousand years ago that the sea was up
to 50 meters over a hundred feet higher
New York Manhattan would be underwater
with the old sea levels where I mean and
the same would go for Cape Town and
Durban
when you and
people tend to focus in on their one
tiny little fact factoid about something
somewhere where there's when you're
gonna look at it from the whole earth
you can't just take one little area so
yes we are having an effect is the earth
warming itself possibly as well as
combined with us as is quite bad but it
is as I say it's not it it's not an it's
not a yes or no answer it's it's
something that needs a lot of thought
and and discussion but while I ponder
the warming of the earth and whether
that's talking so much on drive has got
anything to do with it
let's go back across to Ralph with some
beautiful birds thanks Brent and yes
beautiful they are now these are the
gray crowned cranes but so we were
watching the little Weaver's earlier and
and they were doing a little dance
trying to attract a mate but now what
these two are doing they have obviously
already established they they bond but
there are constantly maintaining it and
it's very much like a couple holding
hands walking into the sunset and
chatting about life and things in
general but these two are doing a little
dance you see how they take if you step
a little bit the same and then you'll
watch and they put their heads up and
they do a little bit of a bob so this is
really keeping and establishing the bond
between them very important as there's a
couple that are going to be bringing up
some chicks and looking after them they
need to know each other inside out and
and these dances and courtship and ways
that they move together it's all
reestablishing those bonds so now I
think I think it was coming from punk
punk rock and something your question
was about if we get punk rock and music
there we go thank you if see punk rock
music you were wondering if we get
cuckoos that come through here in Kenya
absolutely we've got the Emerald spotted
cuckoo which is a very special one for
me I've never seen it we've got the
black cuckoo which says I'm so sad he
does a that's whether I remember at
times I said we've got the classes
cuckoo as well
he doesn't Mikey Mikey Mikey that's his
call we've also got the dear durricks
cuckoo we've got the jacobins cuckoo as
well and so there is a number I think
the la valence as well in French Ave on
so there are a number of cuckoos that do
come through Kenya to answer your
question but folks I just want to show
you this lovely scenery that we are
sitting watching here we've got type B
in the front and we've got water back
and there is a lot of water back in fact
a lot of the fossa water back moving
through their grazing and there are some
elephants in the background and then as
we pan and move across there is a few
more elephant and there's some Impala
and in the background there is a
wonderful while we trying to actually
watch it but the sunset is a little bit
nondescript today it is however making
for lovely colors and so that's a lovely
sight there and we've got some crickets
calling next to us making for a
wonderful sitting here and what I can
hear in front of us as well I think is
some European bee-eaters it's a bit
difficult because they're far off I
can't even see them but they're dying
it's another sign of summer for me one
of the things like the Impala giving
birth the woodland
Kingfisher arriving and the European
bee-eaters as well as the masked Weaver
calls all signs of summer for me and
but here in Kenya it seems that we do
get a little bit of all round or all
year these kind of dropping of the of
the young and the birds calling because
it's a lot more tropical up here sorry
this elephants just getting a little bit
irritated with something and that's why
I'm keep looking over there he's just
trumpeted and Stuckey's ears out I don't
know what he's bothered but sometimes
they can just get a little bit irritated
with the enter lights that are around
him and just throwing the white around
sometimes a little bit bossy
maybe they thinking you a bunch of
minions just move off I'm taking this
waterfall myself maybe he just wants to
be alone oh that's a young topi I
thought that might have been a lion
moving through the grass see I'm sure
there would have been some animals
running off if that was true there's a
lovely set of horns on that Impala still
amazes me the size of the horns on the
Impala here in the Maasai Mara they are
much bigger than that of the ones down
in the low felt or in South Africa I've
never seen an Impala with horns that
size until I came here in in Kenya
that's something new to me so lovelies
hitting yes some of the frogs starting
to kick off the calls as well very
tranquil and you can see that type he's
got a little bit of mud on his horns
he's obviously been trying to show off
the European beat is calling again
wonderful scene
and also here at virtuals kuku it might
be a birch also definitely a cuckoo
might be a white broad or even a see an
adult cool doing is very indicative of
rain and I'm not quite sure we're gonna
get rain anytime soon and maybe he's
just calling for the sake of it nearly
all of the law escarpment in the
background and it seems the birds still
calling a little bit I wonder in the
night birds are going to start to call
I'm sure we'll hear some of the night
jaws and the owls as we on our way back
towards the escarpment but folks it's
been a wonderful day and it's nearly
time for us to say goodbye because we're
gonna start making our way back towards
camp and so thank you for joining us
today it has really been a wonderful
morning and afternoon game drive please
join us once again tomorrow for the
kenyan part of the game drive but in the
meantime good night